the Joe Rogan experience no yeah the
other day someone said humans tamed fire
500,000 years ago and I said that can't
be true
500,000 years ago that's not too long
ago I checked it out it's true and these
weren't even humans these are pre human
I think it was probably one of the two
species back we've been doing this we
didn't changing the environment using
tools using fire for that long the fire
one it's crazy right because it's not
just manipulating a physical thing it's
changing the state right you're you're
doing something whether it's with flint
and stun you know some something to
spark and some tinder you're really
creating changing the state of matter
well we are and will continue to do that
will continue to evolve and one of the
that the reasons that I wanted to see
human origins is in my book I talked
about we've evolved to our natural
lifespan we're now at a maximum 122 is
the longest live human that ostensibly
is on record the so without intervention
we've reached our maximum but why not
now give us what evolution failed to
give us okay why can't we be like other
species that are at the top of their
game are there any factors when you look
at the oldest people that are alive are
there any common factors actually not
really that they do seem to have a
collection of gene variants that
predispose them to get to that long
there's one called Fox o3 that if you've
done your genome we can have a look
23andme
they've done it I have we should look at
it I just tell you you need an A or a T
at a certain position I've got one of
them out of two my kids got two of my
kids out of three have both so they if
they look after themselves might have a
better chance of living longer but
anyway these long live people they tend
to live a long time no matter what they
do often they smoke till ninety years
old really yeah they quit at ninety
there's a few cases of that and they
live another 12 years right right for 22
years right you said 122 years okay
that's one one lady in France but one of
my friends here his name is near
Barzilai he was with me in Israel he's
got a story of when he asked the
centenarian lady
lady that lived over 100 that he knew
why didn't you quit smoking and she said
oh oh for doctors I went to told me to
quit smoking and they've all died going
that's hilarious
what did she do for a living Junko main
I forget the French lady I don't
remember what she did I would imagine
that would play a part like how
stressful your occupation is and yes she
had a great sense of humor that was
probably part of it I used to make jokes
with her reporters all the time one was
uh how many wrinkles do you have
she says I've only got one and I'm
sitting on it big the the other one I
think is even better as a reporter who
was young said you know you're 116 I
hope I see you next year for your
birthday she says I don't see why not
you seem pretty healthy to me Wow and
she made it to 122 now if there been any
anecdotal reports of people that live
longer
well the thews Loren biblically no yeah
I mean not biblical like no not
unsubstantiated reports because I had
heard of there's some people that claim
to have lived like ridiculously long but
they've never really figured out whether
or not it's accurate sure there's
there's a few of those but even even
John Coleman at 2122 there's a big
argument now between us researchers
whether that's even true oh really yeah
it's a massive debate I've got an inbox
full of long angry emails from
scientists what's the evidence point to
the contrary that - so the hypothesis is
that she her identity was subsumed by
her daughter to avoid paying taxes and
this photos of them and there's a blotch
on one photo that matches the daughter
so there's a lot of forensics going on
and people want to subsume the grave and
the French government's not or French
researchers aren't giving up the blood
samples they don't know they don't want
to know so it's probably horseshit
well probably like a hundred years it
could it could be [ __ ] I would say
it doesn't actually matter
goddamn French it doesn't matter people
have lived 117 and that's still pretty
good that's what we know you know if
it's in there we can all live hood live
that long who's gonna complain wouldn't
you like to get one of them
old old old old old people and start
doing work on them yeah just pump him up
with nad get him on a drip well my dad's
remaining on himself so he's not even
hundred yet but he's 80 how's he look
well I wouldn't say he looks young but
his fitness is like a thirty year old
and really he's stronger than me we
tested out in the gym the other day no
way that's embarrassing he can lift more
he's fitter we're going across the
Serengeti and he was leading the charge
if you saw him if you didn't see his
face because he's got grey hair and
whatever physically he put a bag on his
head
you just you'd say his 30 the way he
moves people vary where to put a bag in
your dad's head yeah I shouldn't do that
sorry dad but you think he's 30 really
well he's he's reinvigorated in life so
you know in my family we've got some
Ashkenazi bad genes we tend to die young
and my grandmother died my grandmother
is actually only 15 years older than my
dad and she died a few years ago last 10
years of her life horrible so we know
what's gonna happen in my family
probably to all of us so your mother
your grandmother had your father when
she was 15 years old right whoa yeah
back in the early days of World War two
she apparently was playing around with
her boyfriend she claims to be a virgin
but at that point what something got
some way or that shouldn't have and she
was during high school right so I was
raised by my grandmother she was in her
40s when I was a kid and she was the one
that taught me to always stay young keep
your you know adults ruin everything
that's probably why I work on aging
adults ruin everything
well how was her advice like in terms of
like why how do you avoid what adults
are doing wrong well you know she she'd
grown up during the Depression and then
World War two and then the Communists
came into Hungary and raped it a lot of
people she had no she had had no respect
for humanity so by the time I came along
first of all she put all of her energy
into to me and I'm I was a spoiled brat
as a kid so that that was wasn't helpful
to me I think now as an adult but more
importantly she wanted me to do the best
I could with my life
she said David do what you can to make
this world a better place make sure that
you leave this place better than you
found it and that's what I'm trying to
do Wow what a pro founded piece of
advice for a grandchild she was a rebel
she taught me forget the rules right
kind of like you do I'm going my own way
and we'll see how this goes she so she
went to Australia she said [ __ ] Europe
I'm outta here she went to Australia the
furthest place she could find from your
never went back she went on Bondi Beach
in Sydney in a bikini which was
rebellious and there is she got taken
off the beach pipe by the police would
you have to wear back then are the full
little British thing deep dandy nice
would it Oh down to your knees I think
so did they look like maybe it was a
full one-piece but someone allowed to
show your belly that's what I think but
she was a rebel she went to New Guinea
by herself in the 60s what year was this
where she was wearing a bikini
that would be 56 you couldn't wear a
bikini in the 50s Wow well okay
like those pinup girls right when you
see them they always had one-piece suits
on oh yeah yeah so imagine you Guinea in
the 60s as a woman on her own up in the
highlands she claims to have eaten human
flesh and she spent most of the time
drunk as well